en busca de una justicia igualitaria
bajo la ley el lunes tan sólo un año
después de que la policía de louisville
disparara y matar a una paramédico
afroamericana de 26 años brión a taylor
durante una redada en busca de droga en
su apartamento el fiscal general de eeuu
américa la cndh anunció que se abrirá
una amplia investigación de la policía
local y sus prácticas
tendrás jerzy buzek los investigadores
buscarán pruebas en todos los rincones
del oído y trabajarán con la comunidad
con los funcionarios públicos y con los
agentes policiales todos estos pasos se
darán con un objetivo en mente
garantizar que las políticas y prácticas
policiales sean constitucionales y
legales
la investigación del departamento de
justicia es lo que se conoce como una
investigación de patrón o práctica que
busca aprobar sin métodos
inconstitucionales o ilegales están
arraigados en la fuerza policial está
dirigida tanto a la policía de
louisville como al gobierno del condado
de jefferson por posible abuso de la
fuerza contra manifestantes pacíficos
paradas y registros
institucionales órdenes de registro
ilegales y discriminación racial este
tipo de investigaciones suelen llevar
acuerdos para hacer reformas operativas
de los cuerpos policiales locales
supervisadas por los tribunales la
semana pasada garland anunció una
investigación similar sobre la policía
de mineápolis tras la condena del ex
agente derek joven por el asesinato de
georg floyd nunca se encontraron drogas
en el apartamento de brión a taylor y
ninguno de los agentes implicados ha
sido imputado por su muerte que como la
de floyd provocó protestas masivas
contra la injusticia racial y la
brutalidad policial en 2020 las
investigaciones parecen mostrar la
determinación del gobierno de vaivén por
mantener una vigilancia rigurosa sobre
la aplicación de la ley tras los
disturbios en todo el país